treatments for colorectal cancer include
surgical procedures chemotherapy and
radiation therapy early cancer or polyps
may be removed during a colonoscopy
during this procedure a flexible tube
will be inserted through your anus
in most cases if a polyp is found it
will be removed
if a small area of cancer is found it
will be removed for larger areas of
cancer you may need to have a surgical
procedure to remove the affected part of
your large intestine your surgeon may
remove part of your colon or part or all
of your rectum nearby tissue such as
lymph nodes may also be removed to see
if cancer has spread there in most cases
the remaining ends of your large
intestine will be reattached
but sometimes the surgeon will not
attach the remaining ends right away
instead a procedure may be done to
attach the top end of your large
intestine to an opening in the skin of
your abdomen and the bottom end will be
closed with staples or sutures this new
opening in the skin allows solid waste
to empty into an attached bag usually
the opening is temporary if temporary
the ends of your large intestine will be
reconnected in a leader procedure
chemotherapy radiation therapy or both
may also be recommended either before or
after a surgical procedure
chemotherapy uses drugs to attack and
kill cancer cells radiation therapy is
often used along with chemotherapy
the high-energy rays and radiation
therapy attack and destroy cancer cells
other treatments may also be recommended
for colorectal cancer talk to your
healthcare provider if you have any
questions